everything will be great
they chanted newfound optimism
thanks to this man's victory sovereignty
unequivocally belongs to the people we
will never forget this we will work hard
for Istanbul I promise this to all of
you the world is watching Turkey as they
celebrate a stunning rejection of their
country's increasingly authoritarian
rule there will be democracy in Istanbul
Unity's together in this fraternity
everything will be great and everyone
will see this make a party supporters
will also see this and also believe in
MMO Liu we will make him president too
and as the country's youth will work
much harder to make it happen everything
will be great and will be even better
after this we are very happy democracy
prevailed everything will be great
it's a stinging blow for accept our
Perot and its grip on power
they stifle dissent and the Free Press
shutting down TV channels and newspapers
and used to failed coup to lock up
critics and opponents in their thousands
but now a reckoning a watershed moment
potentially say observers with
implications not just for Turkey
perhaps we're reaching stage after many
years where it will no longer be
possible for leaders who say if you're
against me you're against the people
will succeed and that would be a very
important step forward in an era
dominated by strongmen one of the most
powerful seems suddenly weakened it has
for years been hard to imagine turkey
without erdowan not anymore
Domenic Waghorn Sky News
[Music]